China says that it will stop reporting
asymptomatic cases of covid-19 as they
are impossible really to track it's
another step in the dismantling of
beijing's zero coveted policy now this
major U-turn is bringing with it a wave
of illness the World Health Organization
is mourning that China is facing tough
times ahead
scenes like these were hard to imagine
in Beijing just a few weeks ago parents
and sick children crowding corridors at
this Pediatric Hospital
but scrapping China's strict covert
restrictions has come at a cost and
waves of illness are now spreading
through the city link the queues forming
at clinics and demand for medication
skyrocketing this Pharmacy among many to
have run out of flu medicines and
covered tests
opening up is still being felt but this
is the price we pay for being Freer
feels like it is convenient to go out
and go to places but for myself I must
be more cautious because there is no
protection for us outside now it is
essential that we improve our awareness
in self-protection
foreign
contrast to beijing's eerily quiet
streets and shopping centers illness has
been hitting workers hard and a shortage
of delivery drivers means packages are
piling up
the past week has seen a massive
transformation in China's covert
management domestic travel has opened up
positive cases can isolate at home and
the government has scaled back its
tracing and testing now authorities are
scrambling to react as the virus spreads
more than 14 000 fever clinics have been
opened in hospitals and more than 33 000
clinics have been set up in Community
Health Care institutions
infections are expected to spread across
the country in the coming weeks as
people who haven't been able to travel
return to hometowns and Villages the
World Health Organization warning China
faces a very tough and difficult time as
it adjusts to living with a virus that
authorities tried so hard to Stamp Out
well my next guest is she Shen he is an
associate professor of Health policy and
economics at the Yale School of Public
Health Professor it's good to have you
on the program tonight much of China's
population we understand lacks immunity
because so many have not been infected
with covid 19. as the government eases
this zero covered policy are we going to
see an explosion in covet cases and are
we going to see an explosion also in
fatalities
uh yes uh we will see a surge in the
cases as many other parts of the world
has been experiencing what's the drives
China's Health Care System more strength
is is under invested Primary Care system
so when people are having any illness
they go to hospital which may easily
crash the healthcare system so we see
that the doctors who have been on
vacation has been cut back to serve and
doctors who are tested the code with the
Positive still need to serve in their
own roles so that will be a tough month
ahead for China especially during this
holiday season and China has two holiday
seasons one is the new year the second
is the Lunar New Year which are very
close to each other this year so two
weeks from now China will be seeing a
large flow of population moving from
east to west and to return to their home
county home Village and which may risk
bringing the virus to to their parents
and older adults so this is very risky
and challenging work and so China really
needs to get things done in terms of
vaccinating all the adults in the coming
two weeks Professor you know the rest of
the world is it is attempting to return
to some sense of of
normalcy and we have to keep in mind
that here in Europe but also in North
America when restrictions were lifted
and people started Living Without the
mass for example
um there were there was a slight
increase in cases is that what China has
to go through now and is it going to be
more extreme in China because they had
such a strict policy this zero covet
policy for so long
right indeed as you were mentioned in
China has been implementing the zero
code which protect most people without
any exposure to the virus even if people
receive vaccines most often their last
dose of vaccine was received like 11
months or one year ago so the erosion of
the immunity as a result of infection or
vaccination is huge so that will take
time for China to get a population level
immunity back to a safe level but during
this time period is very important to
establish a medical trial protocol to to
keep people safe at home without going
to hospital only only prioritize those
resources for those really in need of
help and the safeguards the the well
health and well-being of the older
adults and so far China has been
very painful to establish such a policy
because there was no Nation and why the
family doctor system built before the
pandemic and let me ask you as the the
public health policy expert when you
look at zero covid
um and you you see what's happening now
with it being lifted quickly and with
all of these new new cases
what was Zero covet about really then
what was it about
um protecting people was it about sound
public policy or was it more about
a a government or a politician you know
trying to you know hold on to power I
mean do you see was there more politics
than public health in this mix here
yeah I think the key
the key not about zero covet is in the
South zero committed policy was
successful at the beginning of the
pandemic when we knew very little about
the virus to keep the huge population
safe but as the virus gradually evolved
it's very important to adapt that policy
to the changing virus but China has been
very slow in adapting to that have been
maintaining their zero covet by mass
testing quarantine but that's where
painful experienced because that
sacrificed the economic growth and the
social well-being but this is a
sacrifice China planned to buy time to
prepare the healthcare system and
vaccination but we see that over the
last one year and more the vaccination
campaign was very slow and even came to
a halt for the major part of this year
I've got about a minute left Professor
the economic impact of zero covid and
lifting it now and we we see reports
that the streets of Shanghai the streets
of Beijing are still basically deserted
people still don't want to leave their
Apartments when is when is this this
fear when is normal a feeling of normal
when is it going to return
in the in the next couple of months it
will be very painful and sometimes
chaotic but in the long term and it's
welcomed by the International Community
because once China is fully reopened the
the supply chain disruption May
gradually recover and the population flu
and the talent flu will be like more
back to normal but during the next few
months it will be very painful because
China will need to First deal with this
looming Public Health crisis yeah and
you know some possible super spreader
events and plus the winter that's a bad
combination as you said Professor XI
Chen from the Yale School of Public
Health we appreciate your time and your
insights tonight thank you